what's up everyone coming at you from
st. peter's basilica inside of vatican
city right now
this short video will not be able to do
this place justice but all this
not even we've where I am how I got here
and how they keep this place the way
it's kept
look at those massive arches look at
this gorgeous ceiling look at all of the
nuance look at this
and this is just the beginning shakes
out all right look at this
[Music]
[Applause]
check this out check this out
[Music]
did the structure here
it's just gorgeous and I haven't even
walked through even a small part of this
year you cannot mass in this place is
just like the center alley right check
this out and also see vlogging from in
here but you know God it gets you that
content cata gets you that st. Peter's
Basilica this place is crazy
check this out watch it watch this ready
sculpture sculpture is amazing
on the other
I'm seriously I haven't covered
basically any of it it's just like the
main center area and it breaks out in
all these different directions as well
as you go it makes you really realize
how well-kept this place is and just how
amazing it is that humans have have kept
it so freakin clean over the years and
it's apparently one of the most wealth
funded things period the Vatican and the
Catholic Church just one of the most
well funded things ever and you can
totally see that as like this place is
ridiculously well-kept over time and
[Music]
it's just a freakin blessing to be here
experiencing this and looking at it and
being able to share it with you guys so
you know go look it up I've definitely
been thinking about the importance of
taking in like a 360 camera strapped to
my head and just walk through the
Vatican with that so you can see the
Sistine Chapel st. Peter's Basilica so
you can see more of all this amazingly
cool content in your own sort of
three-sixty environment so I've just
been thinking about innovating on
something like that
bringing that to the world always trying
to create always trying to build it was
trying to make [ __ ] better for people
but yeah this place is crazy
all right everyone thanks for checking
out st. Peter's Basilica with me and
make sure to continue passing time doing
cool things look at this how long did it
take to make that how long did it take
to make that right how long did it take
to make this so you know think about
these things why is it so important to
make art or make design things that are
intricate why is it important to spend
hours of time investing into things like
that and versus maybe just being
completely just
on Twitter and eating noise and only
noise and not signals so you know just
consider that as some food for thought
and much love thanks for tuning in
[Music]